how are you feeling fine
[ __ ] i laugh at coven do you really
feel fine
i woke up all kind i've been for the
past uh since
tuesday i was all kinds of achy all
[ __ ] up but now you're
you're better i'm a little achy in the
old legs area but i'm fine
that's weird i'm having aches in my
shoulders and my neck
and i got covered dude i probably i
don't know
did you shake hands with brandon no i
if i did anything it's this and i always
wash my hands too
you're fine okay so brendan needs to
link again so give me a sec
what's up hey what's up
brendan it's brian how are you his
audio's still connecting
all right he should be able to speak now
what's up brendan hi
what's up corona buddy not much buddy
boy i'm just
hanging out pretty much fine i'm pretty
much one hundred percent
little achy chill are we recording
we're rolling yeah we're good we should
let everybody know that brandon and i
did everything wrong in texas we
basically
we practiced no social distancing got up
in front of
350 people as they were laughing at us
and scouting at us and then when we got
off stage
didn't change mics shared it with mileic
and stevie stevie's sick as a [ __ ]
dog he's
the corona poster boy lost his sense of
taste smell
and then we would walk through a crowd
of people going yay
fish bumping like real irresponsible
[ __ ] and now it looks like brendan's
got coronavirus and i'm still waiting
for my tests
right well well here's the thing to all
that
okay well i'm glad you were on that rant
callum and here's the thing though
like i said you know corona is something
you know
i never said it was not real or anything
like that i went about
living my life i got it and
you know what i'm fine well
i'm fine so we should also make a caveat
that most people a lot of people who get
it who are older are not fine
they're in the hospital hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on dude this isn't
a
i'm not gonna do this weird corona thing
with you what most people just like my
doctor
told me he goes what you're what you're
experiencing
97 of all people who get corona
experience the same thing
so this podcast isn't going to be uh
poor
on a poor brian poor brendan this is a
thing where
i was living my life i got corona
i'm fine every my family's fine
we i bunkered down i quorum teamed and
uh that's what it is man
is it weird that i i uh worked out today
is it weird that
on day three i worked out because i have
energy do i look like i'm sick
it's interesting i'm waiting for my
results we'll see what happens but if i
feel if you have it
stevie has it you know my flu symptoms
are not
but it's true i talked to my doctor who
said for the most part
symptoms are all over the place and you
know and i said i gotta be honest with
you i can
i'm i'm moving about my day and he said
that's
very common yeah i mean you should you
shouldn't be moving about your day you
should still stay quarantined if you
think yes i'm staying quarantined i
don't want to give it to anybody yeah
i don't want i don't i'm not going
anywhere yeah because i think i'm trying
to be responsible because i definitely
now
now i understand like i'm you know i
would never go anywhere
and if i had to go anywhere i would wear
a mask and i'd be outside
you know because i just don't i don't
want to be responsible for giving it to
anybody
no that's the whole thing that's why i
do the podcast like this you know
because it is if dude if you have
underlying health conditions if
you're especially if you're obese or if
you're older yeah you do
i mean you know we got it i mean we're
we're morons and we went about you know
going on tour and stuff but we did
everything wrong
yeah i don't agree with that i don't
agree with that b you didn't we did
everything wrong and what fat
like no i just mean i just mean if you
didn't want to catch it
like we went to um when we were on our
way saturday
to do our final shows in san antonio
we got an amber alert that said listen
cases are
spiked and you can't comment so 90 90
people cancelled on us
uh the first show but we have to do we
have to do a show i mean that's the
other thing about being a comic
we sold a lot of tickets i got to do the
show we were responsible washed our
hands and stuff like that but you're
you're gonna catch something i think if
you're if you're performing on stage
with all those people
and that was a risk that i took
responsibility for and i was willing to
take responsibility for so
yeah i think if you were any older if
you if
you if you were your age count and you
had underlying health issues like
obesity or diabetes or you had pneumonia
before something like that
yeah you probably shouldn't be on tour
my man if i wasn't if i wasn't bull
healthy and shredded
you're right and here's the thing i i
hate to do this to you i think you're
jumping on the crota train i don't
really think you have it
i got it come on man i got it to be
honest
you you tested negative you tested
negative and now you're trying to jump
on the train
that's a cough that's a [ __ ] cough
you said that
he goes i think you're jumping on the
corona train that's [ __ ] dude i
saw you huh i saw your test they said
you didn't have it now you took another
one
back took another one because i woke up
all kinds of achy
yeah i don't know dude i don't think you
have it you're just trying to jump on
this train
you don't know dude you heard me cough
just [ __ ] now
hey cat and chin are you guys worried
about any of it
cat okay
i feel like i have a slight fever but i
don't think i have it i think that's
just
from wearing long sleeves to being
around my family because i have to hide
my tattoos that's it
oh they don't know you have tattoos
still uh they do
they just my mom doesn't like seeing it
that's fair
and chin open the podcast with i've been
having pains in my shoulders and my neck
when i told brenda earlier when we do
the test i was like i've been having
these pains forever so i can't tell if
it's from corona or not i don't know
well you had a headache for six years
too
so you know
huh hey chin yeah
this uh girlfriend of yours
nowhere to be found i mean uh
don't stare is it possible that she's
she's being a bird she's being an
amazing human being she's taking care of
her sister's kids in orange county right
now
and if she ends up being a he we don't
give up oh no
hey b i've seen her i've seen her you
guys know her
i i saw him camping yeah she's a cutie
yeah she's adorable can't believe it
and they they have glasses you know what
the you know what the worst
uh thing about this whole corona is so
sunday when i was flying i started to
feel just like
almost i always get sick on planes but i
didn't feel great i'm like man what's
going on
and then i was like it was probably just
like a cold thing
and then monday again didn't feel great
that's when you guys saw me get the iv
and get uh
and i also got tested on monday and then
it was like the symptoms were always
like
you know when you're right about to get
like a bad flu
and yeah like experience the symptoms
like here we go
it's like the very start of a cold or
flu but it just stays there and
it doesn't yeah it doesn't get any worse
yeah and
and then i uh i quarantined for three
days now
and then i woke up this morning
100 100 percent probably i don't know
what it is probably feel better than
i've felt in a long time
but the the worst thing about it is your
taste and smell leaves
yeah i can't like i'll make the
strongest coffee in the world and i
can't taste anything
it's so weird i nothing i can't taste
anything
as you're talking you know what i
realized much to my depression
my eyes look exactly the same thank you
oh they look dude you look identical
there's no change
zero change like brighter they look
different
i'm taking a little more off well i i
was supposed to have lids
and i i'm still seeing this well thanks
a lot dr no help
hey can i be honest about your doctor
yeah
he made you look a little older
rogan rose was telling me to take ivs
[ __ ] and he goes look at you and
look at me that's all you need to say
and i'm like
i don't know dude we look about the same
age
yeah i mean i i don't know what your
thing is against ivs i i've got an iv
every day including today to knock this
thing out
well obviously it's working because
you're 100 you woke up going i have zero
symptoms
and day day two zero and what's the id
what's in the iv are you doing the other
the other magic [ __ ] that make
that that stops you from aging no i've
done nad drips before those suck man
those hurt
you know what i'd rather look older than
deal with that all the time
really i'll tell you what i can't wait
to do my dad doesn't know i have corona
i can't wait to
call him and tell him and then
rub it in his face that's what i can't
wait to do my dad
he's he's a cnn he's a cnn junkie isn't
he oh dude you have no idea
you have no idea you have no idea it's
amazing
it's amazing well we're back on lockdown
i think no we're not nope what do you
mean
l.a feels like it's still on lockdown
not lockdown but
they're close so wineries restaurants
also if you can't dine in
we can dine out if they have like a
patio you do that
you can dine out the the beaches are
closed just for july 4th
but people aren't going to listen to
that new york city is
closing off entire streets and
restaurants just put all their stuff 30
tables outside it's pretty
cool on the streets yeah everyone's
outside yeah it's cool
yeah it's nice i'm curious to
i'm curious to see how long this corona
fair things didn't keep going because
a statistic just came out today with
florida which is just booming with all
these cases
and i sent this to you kellen you look
at the deaths it's point
four of deaths of all the cases point
four percent so it's like
all the death rates are going like this
but the
corona viruses friend like this but
deaths are down so it's like
i don't know how much longer they'll be
able to hang on to this well i i
hope that i come out back positive
because i want to get it so i don't have
to worry about it you know
if there's a time to get it it's
probably now you know what our friend
our friend jeff
foley told us who's the owner of tempest
gym shout out to jeff paligos
i go dude i can't take tiger to your gym
on friday man i
i got hit with that covid and he goes
can i be honest
can you still come and rub it in my face
so i can get it over with
yeah exactly i know
everybody is eventually apparently going
to get it
i mean you know but hopefully we have
better therapeutics
so i talked to my buddy as a doctor who
had it and he works at ucla
and i said what drugs would i take if i
do and he goes right now nothing
nothing i mean you know there's other
things you can take but there's this hiv
drug you can take if it gets really bad
you don't need to do that though if you
don't have i talked to my doctor too
he's like are you experiencing severe
stuff or you know
that's the only worst case there's some
side effects that stuff too talk
together
you know you know you guys know if you
listen to the podcast i've been going
hard on corona and stuff like that but
when i got i was like oh [ __ ]
oh man this this could get dicey you
know even i got scared from all that
fear porn
[ __ ] yeah but even my doctor was like
dude knowing how healthy you are and
stuff like that
you're gonna experience mild symptoms i
bet you get over it really quick
i was like i hope so i had images of you
and i both on ventilators
me too and be like well we can't do the
podcast just [ __ ] dying
like what the [ __ ] those two [ __ ]
who have been going hard in the paint
against corona just [ __ ] died
no i'm glad i got it because now i can
talk from a personal experience
obviously my my experience is different
than some people but for the majority of
people under 40 this is what it's like
dude
can i ask you guys a question can i ask
you a question seriously you look 67
years old
i have i have corona but i'm looking at
my skin tone and the tightness of it and
i don't think i look a day over 40. it's
[ __ ] weird
hey papa now there's there's a few lies
there
you don't have corona you got the test
that said you didn't have it you don't
know that dude i'm waiting for my
[ __ ] let me check hold on let me
check my phone
hold on help brian with it so bad so he
can act like he is something to talk
about
did you guys take the antibodies yeah
you you are you are 100
positive full-blown corona that's what
you said in my test
oh the doctor said full-blown huh yeah
yeah is this the same doctor who did
your lids and called you bro
uh yeah yeah he said bro
he said bro you have full-blown corona
congratulations
you are i believe if anybody can fight
this you can
hi hi stevie how he's doing i go better
saying worse he goes
discouraging man i thought i was feeling
better last night woke up
three times soaked in sweat had to
shower and change the sheets
feel the same today stevie's all [ __ ]
up
well remember too stevie has underlying
health conditions
stevie has had cancer and had his legs
crushed see if he spent
the age of 12 to 13 in a wheelchair and
then he had full-blown
[ __ ] lymphoma and almost died that's
why stevie sleeps
14 hours and steve speedy is just
stevie's delicate like stevie will be
like
oh man we're like what's wrong i guess
ah [ __ ] i didn't get enough sleep like
steve you slept you woke up at noon
hey here's the other thing stevie has no
health insurance
he doesn't have health insurance so i i
better be okay though
i think it'll be okay i think it just
manifests itself differently in people
does your does your girl have it be
i think she's uh sick too yeah but she's
she's feeling better
she's feeling better already did she get
uh did she
did she get tested for it or no she got
tested so we're waiting on the test
we're probably
100 positive you wish
so you have something to talk about i
love it you wish dude you like you're
like tom hanks
dude how am i gonna [ __ ] how did i
get the flu and not corona if you have
corona 100
you gave it to me no but here here's the
thing is
you keep i don't know you need to talk
to your doctor because my doctor goes
you guys
wouldn't have gotten san antonio you
would have got it way before that really
yeah he goes let's say you got to san
antonio on thursday
the symptoms aren't going to show up
that fast
i thought it was between three days and
two weeks
yeah well my my doctors say it's between
four to 14 days
you know what shows me is they have no
[ __ ] clue what they're talking about
but the other thing is is my my
brother-in-law had it
two weeks ago so and i was with him
riding bikes and we were making out
so you guys picked each other up
right yeah so it's in a closed room
yeah if making out with somebody gives
it to you guilty
brian your face is you guys
why is brian's room frozen must be his
wi-fi or
i don't know sorry there he goes you're
back
oh i'm back that was weird i have full
bars
hey here here's the question when can we
go back in the studio
two weeks no not true
because if i'm gonna get tested i talked
to showtime i'm getting tested again on
monday
because i'm feeling negative if you can
come back yeah no
yep as soon as you have a negative test
you can come back that's
right that's what i have to do because
now that i'm positive for sure i'm gonna
have to get a negative test i can't wait
yours gonna be another negative we have
no excuse not to do the podcast
yeah i'm i have a test set up for monday
so i assume but if i'm fine now by
monday i should be all right hopefully
i'm
uh if this is if i have covert then this
is a very mild case of coke i have to
say
but that's how it is like my my
brother-in-law he was like
i had a he goes the worst part for me is
i had a scratchy throat for three days
and he tested positive for it a lot of
young people have very mild symptoms are
they they're asymptomatic
not even young dude 45 98
have the same symptoms quit spreading
lies brian
you have it and it's not [ __ ] dude i
have it
it's not
now what you what you shouldn't do brian
is go by go to your parents
though because you're dead i know i'm
not i'm not i'm not i had to cancel that
yeah i can't take that risk no i mean
like my uh
my girls parents they're usually always
overwatching tiger in boston they're not
coming over probably for two weeks
yeah that's the bummer um that is the
bar
but uh i can't risk getting them sick
were you going for anything
particularly are you just going to see
him just go on and take my kids
and hang with you know just kind of get
away
with my grandparents you can reschedule
though i love hanging with my parents
i i don't take it for granted that
there's still a lot of great people
let's yeah i assume you like hanging
with them
you and your dad get into good arguments
though i love hanging with them but yeah
we argue like cats and dogs
and you haven't told him you have you
tested positive i was waiting for me
well i was waiting because if i was on a
ventilator he'd been you know
like i [ __ ] told you so i've been
waving i've been i've been in the
corona tall grass
did you go on a um on a bike ride today
i sure did brian and then what else i
did 15 miles today and then what else
i'm doing
is i'm uh i'm building a bike right now
in the garage a new bike i'm building a
new bike from ymt
i didn't know you could build something
are you good with i don't picture you as
being a mechanical guy with
your hands we'll picture this dick in
your mouth i've been doing it for a long
time
i don't know about that dude i've never
seen you fix anything you're not a
mechanical guy
this is the third bike i put together
i'll uh i'll send you a picture of it
i'll i
i should video it it's like these yt
bikes come pretty
pretty standard but i'll switch out the
shocks the forks you know what i'm
talking about
my neighbor my neighbor builds
motorcycles he has a motorcycle shop and
he said
he said uh if it's broke i can fix it
and i said what's broke he goes
anything i can fix it and i went that's
a town
that's a town that i don't have it's
kind of
it's not a town it's just let's just
if you if that's you if that's what
you're into like i was never in bikes
before this the now balls deep in them
and
i learned how to fix the chain if it
breaks the tire's not right
right it's like just information that's
how i am with horses man
the horses for horses [ __ ] wild i'll
break it you know what i mean
what if a horse breaks its leg you can
still kill it
nah i'm one of the few people that can
splint a horse i could splint a horse
oh what i do is i chop i i karate chop
his neck
and he i hit a nerve and he gets
paralyzed and i pull
i set the bone wrap it and then he's
fine
i'll tell you what daddy's about to lose
some weight because without taste i
don't feel like eating anything so if
the only thing i feel is i'm a little
light-headed because i've been eating
i don't know damn near two days now yeah
it kills your appetite
well i'm hungry but i just if i can't
taste it what's the point
i wish there's a pill so i would have
this all the time and i'd be
so skinny well
i got myself a little um i got myself
some chicken
chicken soup and it was delicious from
benny's tacos
rotisserie chicken vegetable soup
and throw the potatoes out because you
know i don't need night shades
oh yeah you can't have night shades
that's right
you could have night shades it truly
helped my mobility
meanwhile i called you today because my
neck keeps catching anybody
annoying there's nothing more annoying
brian goes uh dude my neck i go
have you done anything he goes no dude
but all the years of
wrestling and jiu jitsu my neck hurts
oh really oh yeah
i bug you oh i knew that would bug you
hey and then now your neck hurts and you
have corona
weird dude my neck if anybody's a
physical therapist please reach out to
me
i need to figure this out because my
neck keeps catching when i go like that
it goes
and it hurts like a [ __ ] it scares me
yeah it's nothing
hey here's the other thing you don't
know yeah it's absolutely you're saying
my corona and my neck are nothing you
can't i'm not believing any of it
hey remember when you drove down to san
diego and you missed the podcast and you
were there for
10 hours getting all sorts of tests
turns out i'm very healthy they didn't
they didn't do any mris on your
spine or your neck or anything they did
i gotta call them and see what the [ __ ]
they saw
if they if if if you would have had like
a dead disc or something that i would
assume they would have
alerted you i don't know hopefully that
would be bad to have a dead disc
what the [ __ ] is that what do they do
about that that's what i have
i mean it depends how bad it is they can
do surgery
but if you'll see on the mri it's like
there's the disc and then it's like
black
it's dark do you have that
and do you have limited motion on your
neck i don't i don't notice that with
you
uh it's a little stiff thanks travis
brown
he did that well you we're training for
it with j jake
jack mays did it jack jack you guys
landed you landed on your [ __ ] head i
thought
and then when i went to go shoot in on
uh droughts brownie sprawled
right on my neck so that made it even
worse i remember you walking around for
like three months like
you could move your neck yeah
and your girl your girlfriend was like
why aren't why aren't you doing anything
because it'll talking about it it's not
gonna [ __ ] help it
no what are you gonna do you just gotta
be in pain all the time
that's it chad i like your black couch
ikea hey hey chin and cat you guys can
talk you know you can't get corona
through the zoom meetings right
yeah i know that there's nothing to
say right now are you are you guys
worried at all
uh no i had my family over for
the week while my sister moved in so i
was a little worried about that
but i don't think i have it honestly
we don't really we got we don't hug or
we don't get that close to each other we
don't actually
really they don't yeah we don't but
even even uh the fist bump is rare with
us jim we kind of just come in and say
what's up but we keep our distance
theo theo was worried about it because
he was going to see his mom who's
99 years old and uh he was worried about
giving it to her
did he get his husband yeah he got a
test i think yesterday or today
and he was you know but he says he
doesn't feel anything chappelle say
don't feel anything you don't feel
anything i think you know who
knows how's mala can we check with him
yeah i checked with him
he's fine
what did molex say that he's fine dude
your thing keeps freezing huh
yeah but not my thing i have full bars
no i know you keep saying that but yours
is the only one that keeps freezing you
know you say bars i'm worried you're not
on wi-fi bro
yeah right my wife all right good
hopefully
it could be better but whatever it's all
good
i'll go downstairs if i have too close
to my router no it's not too bad
yeah so i guess we could you can't even
leave the house on calen
we can't do anything not until i know
what the [ __ ] is going on
and if i do if i am positive i do have
to stay here
yeah i'm quarantined and away from the
family
what's that i said i'm quarantined just
in my basement away from the family but
then
i'll go outside i'll ride my bike you're
pulling your chris cuomo
yeah chris bombo yeah
that's exactly what i'm doing you know
what's weird about chris como because
you know i'm just
chilling especially when i thought i was
going to be on a ventilator so i was
watching a lot of just
staying in the basement watching shows
is
i don't agree with a lot of chris
cuomo's uh
points of views especially politically
and everything he's doing but i like him
as a person
and he's funny as hell man he's a good
guy
i don't know i used to know him like
fairly i know you always talk highly of
them and
it's so funny because he had a he had
these two guys on there
uh you know the guy who was defending
his house with the gun
yes the protesters he had him and his
lawyer on there and the lawyer was
literally ramble out something and chris
comey goes listen i don't know what the
hell you're talking about i didn't know
what
if that was english because then we're
gonna we're gonna stop this interview
right now it was so funny man
because i don't know chris chris i don't
think chris wanted to do that job at
first
from what i hear and then he um
chris is like chris is uh my my
recollection of chris
he was a really humble dude and and just
a [ __ ]
just a like an athletic humble guy who
was just all the girls liked and
just a regular dude but um he also like
was very aware
that he was in his father and brother's
shadow he had to deal with that [ __ ] all
the time
his father was the governor yeah long
time governor his father is a legend in
new york
are they kind of like the kennedys of
new york town yes they're
they're they're a dynasty and and um and
you know remember chris was also hanging
out with the kennedys and all those
people
he grew up he grew up in in gracie
mansion i mean he he lived in gracie
manchester
what's crazy man that's where the mayor
of new york live the governor of new
york lives i mean it's a big deal so
he grew up as royalty in a way but chris
was always a guy
from what i remember and i knew him as a
young guy who was
like he was just humble and very aware
of that liability he hated it
he was like a guy who's just he didn't
he wanted to be taken seriously
yes and he was also but he was also like
some guy like remember one time this guy
goes uh something like uh he saw chris
chris
very big and muscular iq and the guy
said something like i ran a 4 5 40
to chris and chris chris was sitting
there with his
hands in his back and he goes well i i
have enough trouble just waking up in
the morning dude
it was [ __ ] great i don't want to
compete with you on this [ __ ]
he was a fan too he would come to my
stand up and you know he loved it
so good guy
hey corona kids this episode of firing
the kid is brought to you by the one the
only
on it there's a reason why me and kyle
stay healthy man
that's why we weren't so worried about
corona because we're healthy kids
take the on it baby on it
on it on it.com fighter get your
freaking hem protein your regular
protein get the best coffee on planet
earth
i'm talking about pro oil oh dude how
about their coffee dude caffeinated
crystals
extra crystals wake show ass i've not
had the [ __ ] yeah
coffee i've not had it but i like it and
uh
i want to try that but i i do take my
krill oil i've done my research on fish
oil and for whatever reason krill oil is
the
i guess the most readily available or
less toxic i don't know what it is but
they do all their research they do all
they got doctors to do all the research
whenever they make their
cell phones if you guys need a workout
at home they got on-demand workouts run
at six they got battle ropes they got
kettlebells maces everything you need go
to on it.com slash fighter 10
off a lot of those workouts are 30
minutes and they're all you need
they're incredible on it.com slash
fighter 10 off
talk to me about wolf brandon talk to me
about that that thing you can
wear on your on your wrist that tells
you everything about
your heart rate about your recovery
about your sleep
cycles i know you you swear by it yeah i
swear
by it because i was sick of guessing how
many calories i was burning while my
thick ass was on the mountain on my bike
so i said i need something
that measures my heart rate 100 times
every second i'm talking about that
whoop strap
that whoop strap monitors my heart rate
it takes the strain
it takes my my body my mass everything
how much rest i'm getting sleep
if i should ride today if i should rest
my recovery
everything there's no more guesswork it
takes all of that
and puts it on a simple interface on
your phone you connect your phone via
bluetooth
and it's constantly monitoring your
heart rate and uh it's one of a kind man
it's the future it's kind of the future
of health it seems future fitness
i don't know why you wouldn't wear it
you just wear it all the time it's
waterproof i swim with mine i shower
with mine i play with my kids with mine
i do everything with it i gotta i gotta
get one
i literally as i hear you talk about it
when we're not on air i i realized i had
to get one yeah thick boy bike club step
your game up take the guesswork out when
you're on that bike you know exactly how
much you're putting in
if you should take the next day off if
what kind of sleep you got go to
woop.com promo code fighter
and you save 15 that's woop.com promo
code fighter
get the whoop strap take the guesswork
out know how much you're putting into
your workouts nope
should rest you know how much sleep
you're getting it's super important man
woop.com promo code fighter
jim what do we got for current events
all right
hey brian i don't know like you're low
energy and you don't have corona that's
what bothers me the most
dude i had [ __ ] i don't know now
you're trying to speed through the
podcast
i'm sorry what do you have to do
dude i have aches what do you have to do
i'm achy why why do you not believe i
have corona ah
cause i know you i [ __ ] sweat through
my i sweat
i sweat last night all right you guys
gonna be over here on the right
okay let's start with cats
okay so do you remember the movie that
brendan said he made
a small cameo in the tax collector no
well the trailer just released and i
tried really hard and i could not find
brendan to save my life
i'm in there i'm in there i'm the i'm
the cartel members with the mask on
you'll see me three times
okay will you point yourself out when we
play it well as soon as you see guys
with mask on
i'm them let me see so just
i'm in it a little more than brian was
in the joker
but just so you know when we watch oh
there we go
so when watch the video it's hard to
hear yourselves talk so just know that
don't watch it okay we won't say
anything but i'll tell you when you see
me
oh that was me
you heard of me
what have you heard how are you the
[Music]
devil
[Music]
every gang in l.a has to pay the taxes
so home
[Music]
[Music]
there's no excuses do not
test that
guys look like a couple of monsters
[Music]
you got your wife
[Music]
it's good brandon
that was good that's me you want to cut
your heart out
can't run what's left i got 380 on each
ankle 38 in my right 25 on my left chop
in the trunk blocking my phone
[Music]
me
is a hell of an actor oh dude he is
phenomenal i
that was my biggest take away from doing
that movie the the the three second nap
i had in that movie just being on set
for like three or four days with shia
labeouf
my god he is a [ __ ] fantastic actor
he's so goddamn good here's what's
interesting about that is that movie
i didn't i didn't know when it was
coming out but it's a david ayers movie
who did training day he did fury
he did suicide uh squad all that but he
um in order to make that movie one of
the act that bobby soto's father
is connected to the mexican cartel
so it's it's based off a true story but
where they
shot it they shot in straight ghettos of
los angeles
but nobody messed with the with the sets
or
any of the shoots because they had real
like shot callers and gang members for
security
it was really cool it was really really
cool scary but cool
that's pretty wild yeah yeah man he's
something else that kid he's something
the [ __ ] else
oh dude i'm he is such a [ __ ] talent
it's insane
you gotta love acting to get that into
it you don't care
the way he does everything he's about
for fury he
thought it would look more realistic if
he got a tooth removed
so he actually took a tooth out to film
fury for this movie tax collector
his his uh character creeper has the
chest tattoo that says i forget what it
might say creeper
he got a real tattoo across his chest
that says creeper
jesus christ well yeah i'm i'm um
not an actor he's as he's as committed
as they
as they get then also you look at what
he does to give back to
you know underprivileged kids it's
insane you talk about a good dude man
he's a great dude he came up really he
had no money his dad was selling hot
dogs i think at the stadium it's dodger
stadium
yeah he has a very tough upbringing but
also you look at
uh think about shia labeouf he did that
movie uh
peanut butter falcon which got so much
high praise
then he did the other one honeyboy which
was his life story that he wrote and
directed
and now he did this one as well with
david ayers he's a beast man
he's special special guy man steven
spielberg said that
steven spielberg saw him in something
and said this kid is the future
yeah phenomenal very rare you put him in
that indiana jones i'll tell you what
though
after being on that set and like seeing
that like the dramatic roles and he's
this gangster stuff like that
i was like oh this isn't for me like i
had to watch him i had to watch
him play this serious role uh this scene
out over and over
like it's the most dramatic scene in the
movie and he kept doing it over and over
i was like
ah man this is that i do not want to do
that
i was like joaquin phoenix watching him
go over and over like that's like
that's a masochistic process you got to
kind of like
it's not comfortable to be in that
position no yeah
i think if it was a if it was like a
movie of like
all our friends and it was funny like we
did for fighting kid 3d that would be
fun but
to do like a serious role movie like
that and you're shooting for months
that's that's just i i knew like you
know off the bat i'm like oh that's not
for me this
this life isn't for me sitting in a
trailer waiting till i go on switching
outfits doing makeup
stand up stand up for me stand up stand
up stand up yeah i like stand up and
podcasting i'm a cartel guy on there
i've i
i haven't seen the the final movie you
have no idea how much i'm in it
i get auditions my mind's in there
nothing you know i have no idea how much
i'm in it
i did audition for a really fun series
that i've just almost finished
called the boys about superheroes that
are bad
these guys are superheroes and they're
just they're just take advantage of
their powers
[Music]
i i auditioned for it i would never have
auditioned for something but i saw and i
went this is a [ __ ] good role oh did
you get it you know
i don't know yet but uh it would be
something i would do well that'd be cool
because i could kill it i could kill it
play just sort of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] of a uh
superhero do you think you're gonna
start maybe doing some more auditions
for you for stuff that you want to do
now or no
i don't think so bob i think the truth
is that i just want to stick to stand-up
and podcasting unless it's like a good
role or something
maybe but i've never liked acting
because i don't like the process it's a
little bit like skiing skiing's fun when
you're on the hill and you're going down
the hill
it's getting all the gear and the cold
and all that the amount of
it's just the [ __ ] you'd go through with
i just never liked the process i hate to
say it
i have to admit that to myself i'm at
53. i spent my whole life
acting and trying to be an actor and i
realized that so much of it was just my
if you have shia labeouf bradley cooper
you love acting those guys
love it uh joaquin phoenix all those
guys me
i had options i liked being funny i like
doing stand up that's when i feel
the best that's what i feel the most
alive thank god you're really good at
stand up you know yeah you know if you
go down that road of acting and that's
your passion and you're trained in it
and you get to 53 years old and you
realize man maybe i don't want to do
this a lot of you guys are stuck you
know
they're stuck and you know people are
not paying actors because they don't
have to you don't want to do that role
we'll just go over here no problem you
don't want to do it for scale plus 10
percent
that's all right you're great but we
have three other dudes or maybe 10 other
guys who are really good
i was talking to tom segura about this
uh last night like thank god we're able
to still do our podcast and stuff like
that because
you know you even with this corona stuff
it's maybe
you know especially me getting crown
it's like all right how much do i want
to do the road until they figure stuff
out stuff like that but it's like i
thank god i have that option to decide
what i want to do
thanks to podcasting thanks to you and
me
doing this [ __ ] how many years ago
deciding to [ __ ] ride it to the
wheels
seven years i think
crazy yeah but that will be my acting
debut
okay i might have a mask on you will see
me in the restaurant as well i think
unless
they edit me out of the whole thing but
uh
okay okay on mad tv sometimes you'd have
to you have to be in four hours of
makeup just to be
in the background because you'd be
wearing prosthetics
you'd be wearing plastic they paint
rubber [ __ ]
face pieces on you well how about how
about jim carrey to play the grinch they
said he's in makeup for 14 hours
sometimes
you'd go crazy you have to sit there
yes i'd go crazy it wasn't 14 hours but
it was
i promise it was a long time it was more
like five hours let's be like no no no
as long as that because he said he had
to get some training some mental
training to get through it
yeah usually it's usually it's four
hours i i've done
i've done exactly that makeup so i can
tell you oh you've done the grinch
yeah i've done that kind of makeup i've
had that kind of crazy amount of makeup
on
so a lot of times it's a it's a face
mask that you're wearing
um you have a bald paint and you have a
wig there's a lot i i've done it i've
done it
i dressed up i did uh hold on spending
two hours in the morning getting in one
hour and evening get out
you came out oh okay sorry you're right
it takes me thanks it'll take more than
14 hours it'll take more than uh two
hours though i i've been in makeup for
as long as three hours three and a half
hours
i mean listen how much do you get paid
for the grinch shut your [ __ ] mouth
get in the mail there for two hours i
was thinking oh you know what
i'm at 14 hours total come on man you
can go a little crazy though because
what happens is you're you're in that
mask and you can't really eat or do
anything
you have to drink out of a straw and you
can't move so you're you're all you're
in that
you're wearing essentially uh
glue and rubber on your face
for 16 hours and then you go home and it
takes an hour to get out then you go
home you wake up really early and you
start all over again it's a [ __ ]
it's claustrophobic yes
i'm seeing how much you got paid
a lot oh you may oh he made uh
he made 30 oh 32 million listen
for 32 million i will sit in that chair
for 24 hours straight you're feeling
i'll suck i'll suck your dick for
i'll suck your dick for for three months
straight
for 32 million dollars i'd suck your
dick for your monster or i'll just make
uh grinch
too you know you don't have to suck or
i'd suck your dick okay
well i feel like you do that for free
and a little bit of makeup
that's [ __ ] dude i need 32 i mean 32
million dollars
a little rouge a little rouge on the
lips
i'll wear a wig yeah uh that movie does
look sick though
i just like david ayers and uh shiloh
buff so i hope it does well
yeah yeah
okay so the next story is a couple in
ohio were running errands and they
decided to go pick up pizza from little
caesars when they
picked it up they got in the car started
driving the wife noticed that there was
a backward swatzika
on the pizza in pepperoni they ended up
reaching out to little caesars to see
how this could have happened and after
an investigation they found out that
this was an inside joke between the
workers at that particular location and
this pizza wasn't supposed to be
sold to any customer and that's the
reason why it wasn't cut
so they're saying it was an insensitive
inside joke with people who are working
that shift
and little caesars is just trying to
rectify the situation with the family
behind the scenes
did they so is that a is that a that's a
backwards swastika right
backwards which is actually the symbol
for buddhism
yeah it's a symbol for good fortune
actually yes so
right now you can see a lot of people
who right now they have sorries on
where they're then and they have that
that exact diagram all over it yep
yeah and the nazis took it over but
here's the thing though is
we're giving these little caesar pizza
employees too much credit if we think
they were doing the hindu
sign there yeah
probably true
what else you got all right well caesar
sucks dick anyway just
because you can eat a swastika doesn't
mean it's in good
taste but also i i thought little caesar
was
square slices did they go to round
slices oh yeah
they did a revamp recently of uh their
pizza i think it tastes better i think i
tried it maybe a couple months ago and
it was pretty good
dude i'll tell you what i did when i was
uh stressed out
a few weeks ago i uh domino's for six
nights in a row
what i do is i get a large pepperoni uh
hand tossed pizza and i put extra sauce
on it so you know that shit's fresh
and it is so goddamn good delicious when
it comes to like
fast pizza like that ain't nobody better
than dominoes
i think i want pizza now that's so nice
dude
i'm hungry that but that pizza was in
poor
taste even though they were trying to
make pizza
racism more palatable
okay so the next story is there was a
university in japan that recently
opened up their uh curriculum to allow
people to get a masters in ninja studies
and what ended up happening was there's
a 45 year old man who
went to that university in order to
we're studying history traditions and
fighting techniques of a ninja
he is officially the first man to have a
masters in ninja studies
now did he minor in nerdism
probably i'm not sure but uh
yeah that's the thing now good now
uh why do you think you should work for
our corporation um
i uh i have a master's degree in ninja
i'm a ninja apparently he's trying to
know how to climb a mountain quietly
because you know
yeah what's the curriculum how do we
know what they're
not exactly we just know that he has to
study the history of ninjas
i guess where it started how it
progressed what they did
and then he had to learn some martial
arts i don't
i don't really know exactly where you go
with that but
it took him two years and he has his
masters well you have to study ninjutsu
which is illegal in ufc because it's too
deadly
have you ever in your in all your dead
times fighting do you ever
spar with a guy who was a kung fu guy no
never we didn't have the time for
[ __ ]
also i like how that ninja's out of
shape
yeah that's a good point that's a good
point
not
is that a belt or is it a sweatshirt
wrapped around his waist
uh no those are baggy pants brendan
tucked in apparently he thinks he lives
in the 1500s
he kind of looks like an asian elon musk
yes
good call cat
maybe it's gone all right next event
okay so with the nfl returning this fall
uh they have found that they are losing
way too much money i think it was about
three billion dollars by not having fans
watch the games so what they're gonna do
is they're trying to figure out a way
to have fans in the arena while the
games are happening
while also absolving them from any sort
of liability from
them getting coveted if they do contract
it at the game
so they're in the works of creating a
coven waiver
for fans to attend in the fall good idea
that's a great idea
again leave it up to the fans let them
decide the risk
of going to the nfl games worth it for
them to correct
correct leave it up to people to make
that decision
i think that's the way to do it you have
to leave it up to individuals
that's the way to do it with everything
when it comes to society open
restaurants everything man look we see
that we
like him but the death rate's completely
down brandon you're speaking like a
capitalist an
american i know are you saying the
individuals should have respond take
responsibility for themselves
i'm speaking like someone who's gonna
move the [ __ ] to texas
yeah man i mean that's that's uh that is
the fundamental divide it seems
in the big great debate that you're
starting to be thrown into brennan which
is the idea that
you know part of part of the capitalist
system is just as an individual if you
come up with an idea like thick boy
or whatever it might be and you take a
risk and you put your money into it
you can make money and you benefit from
that now
it should be noted that you brendan and
myself
spend 50 percent of our day and our year
working for someone else what do i mean
by that
we pay 50 in taxes um so
so that's fine that's fine when
socialists talk about
taxing us 70 to 80 percent anybody who
makes a lot of money
okay how do you justify that and do you
think that
do you think that your system which
would be the federal government to
redistribute that wealth do you really
think that they are
the best people to do that and make
everybody richer because what happens
why would you penalize people like
yourself or entrepreneurs
who take risks who have an imagination
who are willing to work hard and who are
smart
to uh why would you penalize them why
would you take 80 of their money
we know that in most socialist countries
what happens when you do that and i'm
not speaking i'm just saying
it's it's really hard to incentivize
people to do that why would i do that
and put all that effort if you're going
to take 80 of my money i already
50 of my day let me say it again and
your day is spent working for someone
else
that's fine i'm not up in the street
protesting but how much more do you want
in my mind well not if
that's why a lot of people are moving to
texas because it doesn't make a lot of
sense but if you are somebody who
benefits or if you are somebody in
government
all due respect who were in academia who
doesn't who's not entrepreneurial
who has a fixed income if you're
somebody in the media
same thing and you don't know what it's
like to run a business you've never
you've never had to build the business
you've never had to build a brand which
is
all what what stand-up is all about
podcasting is all about
how are you going to know what that
takes how are you going to really
appreciate
how hard it is then not only to get
there
but how do you want me to be okay with
taking 70 of my money
after that am i getting penalized for
that i didn't always
have a lot of money as you know and i
went to a lot of failure and a lot of
people do
who who are now making money so what
what this system was found on was the
idea that an individual no matter who
you are
if you have a really good idea and you
take a risk you might just get lucky
enough to make a billion dollars
okay so that that that's something that
i think has to be
preserved and it's under attack you hear
people
equating capitalism with racism and
i mean i can get into it but i'm not
going to
but i mean this is what's this is what's
under attack and i don't think it's
very advantageous to anybody agree
yeah dude and people get mad at me
they're like you're you're becoming this
right-wing guy no no
i'm not i'm not i'm reasonable i just
want the best for everybody man
that's all trying to figure it out all
right
all right uh this is the western
australian premier mark mcgowan talking
about a
a kid who was rejected from getting into
a pub because of his mullet
so the premier league i agree with that
okay the premiere
what's that
so this is like a high governing
official right so he's a member of the
two houses of parliament for western
australia
uh that's all we need to know about this
guy so he's actually talking about it at
a press conference and it's actually
pretty funny i'll play for you
oh i just encourage people with mullets
to rise up
and rebel against these extreme
rules pubs are imposing um i think you
should be free to have a mullet
we actually answered it during the
french press conference too
that's so funny like
well no i don't think he should be
allowed in there with a mod
that's a terrible mullet dude yeah it's
a scraggly well at least
theo puts a little effort into it god
bless him
god bless that big blonde mullet kid all
right
crazy one this is in miami
and i'll play the video for you first so
it's it's actually at the miami airport
and it's a cop
punch are slapping a girl
oh and also the guy that posted this is
billy corbin your buddy
boy billy
oh so he smacked her
and then they took her down and arrested
her so apparently this girl
she showed up late at the airport at
american airlines and then she started
like uh
insulting and then also threatening the
people that worked there and then
they told her go to another airlines she
started threatening more people so the
cops are called that guy happens to be
according to this video she might be
black
and she was saying like oh you're you're
you're what you're acting like you're
white but you're black
and then she apparently put her head on
his chin and that's what he did
smack out she did and if you if that's
called assault actually if you come out
if you're threatening a police officer
and you put your head on her chin on his
chin like that you get arrested
that's that's considered you know it
still that still doesn't
uh give people a free pass to slap the
[ __ ] out of a female
he could have apprehended her and like
put her to the ground and arrested her
but you don't have to
slap her you slap me
i don't think he's going to get in
trouble though ironically i think what's
going to happen is he
so he said he he i don't know i mean i
do think i do think that was totally
unnecessary
to be excessive force slapping a female
yeah so he wasn't actually fired there's
an investigation he's on he they said
they relieved him of his duty so he
can't
he doesn't have the powers of a cop
anymore but he's not necessarily uh
fired i don't know what that woman's
problem was she was obviously
threatening they're going to go into her
history too she's not like you know
you're just being nasty to a police
officer
she sucks too they both suck yeah you
can't do that
i agree it's probably not a good idea
you know
no she's getting taken a hit though
um oh this is i thought was awesome
so this la city councilman he's talking
about developing a department
that's not like the cops well they don't
have weapons but they're like social
workers or people that understand you
know mental
illnesses to go to non-violent crimes or
non-violence
right so i'll play this real quick for
you
we're looking at non-violent situations
where we can send unarmed
trained people to address those
concerns what we're talking about is
trying to provide
the most efficient service
to this city that we can provide
and that's going to take shifting
resources i however believe
that if you have a police department
that's focused
on police related matters you have
quicker response time and i think you'll
get
better service when you're talking about
mental health issues like you referenced
earlier who better to be the first on
the scene
than a mental health professional or
social worker
individuals that know how to reach and
to
communicate with people what do you guys
think
i i don't know my area of expertise
seems to make sense
like and it also seems like it might
de-escalate
the situation like if you have a guy
come up these cops who are used to
dealing with murders and
criminals and violent you know offenders
if you have someone come up who has
you know no gun or nothing like that
they're just trying to de-escalate
something and
figure out a solution to the problem it
makes sense
more so than i think a cop who's you
know there to really you know take care
of some
dangerous situation well this is the
positive thing i think of the protests
and george floyd and all that
where now as americans we start we start
being more surgical about how we
approach
law enforcement and problems right and
so in that sense i think it's pretty
cool
like now you're able to see kind of like
how
um how there's nuance and there's
details
you know involved in what they mean by
defunding the police or rearranging a
police department
maybe mental health professionals are
way better in this situation maybe cops
don't even want to deal with that they
want
they want to stop real crime so that's a
good that's a good
intelligent uh suggestion uh
again i i that's why i get encouraged
right now there are these protests and
people are really upset and
things as americans always do we swing
all the way right all the way left all
the way
to one direction or another but then you
know as
these things get opened up for debate we
have to get to the level of detail and
legislation
now we start getting a little bit more
most people are sensible and we get a
little bit more detailed now it's like
all right we're not talking about
getting rid of the whole police
department like minnesota minneapolis
trying to get rid of their [ __ ]
police department with the city council
i mean good luck i don't know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about you want to
get rid of
i mean you know look look yeah look look
at the crime rate there right now but
then also look at new york
who defunded i think a billion dollars
in it they've it's never been higher
crime
it's not even that it's not even that de
blasio is not behind his police force de
blasio
hates his police force so when when when
the [ __ ] police feel like their mayor
is
behind them they don't want to [ __ ]
get in trouble
they don't they they get resentful and
they're like this
[ __ ] doesn't know the first
thing about policing which he doesn't so
what happens is
shootings are up some crazy amount crime
is
everywhere and now new york very quickly
goes back to what it was
when i was there in the 80s dangerous
70s
when you were so was terrible de
blasio's
you know good luck with that that's a
gamble did you see what's happening in
atlanta
they stopped answering calls the police
stopped going to
what happened in baltimore homicide
homicide rates came up i think 65
percent
yeah because the police get terrified
they get tired and also the police are
like oh we're the enemy we're public
enemy number one
the majority of them are good people
like oh you want to treat us like [ __ ]
watch what happens well in baltimore the
majority of them are black
the huge part of the police commissioner
the police chief is black
the the uh the the guy under him is
black the person under him is black
the city council is primarily black so
you know
even in in that city they were like i
don't want to get in trouble for this
yep
move on so fourth of july is just around
the corner
and there's this public service
announcement from the us consumer
product
safety commission and this video is
supposed to make you not want to use
fireworks but to everyone that's
watching it it just makes them want to
do fireworks even more so i'll play it
for you
and they have this music in the
background too that's fun
what happened there it's just everything
exploding people getting their hands
blown off their heads
yeah that's bad
man it's not good for your head
jesus christ
[Music]
yeah that's not good
[Laughter]
this is awesome jesus christ what are
those fireworks
big ones sorry my corona
hey is uh a bit are fireworks banned in
every state right now or is it just
california we can't have any fun
um
it'd be great if chin's uh search
history popped up and it's just like all
like scat babes [ __ ] videos
fighting good hiding dead bodies
it says only only massachusetts bans the
sale of it and use of it
and then two states illinois and vermont
permit the sale
and use only wire or wood stick
sparklers and other novelties
weird yeah i thought it was way more
expensive
so i i guess we're the only state that
says we can't have them
well we can actually still buy them we
just can't do it in certain cities all
right how is this working how is our
zoom podcast working
pretty well right how far it's okay yeah
it's not too bad
i mean obviously i'm an audio guy so
this is kind of frustrating but
oh well it still works yeah
you want another one yeah
all right let's see all right do you
guys know who lily reinhardt is
no neither do i but she's a character in
riverdale she's a really hot girl and
she used an image of herself
to bring attention to brianna taylor's
murder
and then it was her using soccer so this
is what she wrote that's [ __ ]
hilarious
hold on now that my cybo's gotten your
attention
taylor's
that she's using herself to promote
herself for this you know
and people are pissed yeah so she
apologized and deleted it too yeah
she tried very hard to be honest on my
igg tv uh
that i'm still learning trying to be
better understand that my catch came off
as tone deaf
i truly had good intentions i not think
though
yeah i i didn't view that as incentive i
think people are like oh look at the
titties they see
you know that she's like you know
because that's what's going to draw
people's attention she would have posted
a picture
of brianna taylor it wouldn't got
nowhere near as much as attention so
i think that was her thinking behind it
you do see how it's kind of self-serving
to you though
a little bit well she's an actress so i
don't care
also she's hey brian thanks a lot thanks
a lot for standing up for black
that's her yeah
the actress that passed away she was in
the eminent movie do you remember
wait yes yeah but let me get away can i
ask you a question
let me guess lily reinhardt is not
uh is not into racism and she doesn't
like the killing of innocent black
people is that what she's
i just want to know yeah yeah oh okay
good well i'm glad listen i
i used to be pro that but now that lily
has posted that
i now have realized the error of my ways
so thank you lily for making a
difference
yeah true thanks a lot we appreciate it
you're making a big difference
lily do me a favor how is chicago going
can you go fix that too
maybe maybe a blue picture will fix it
yeah
yeah go go there and see what they say
in the hood there because they need your
help as well
okay give us one more chin give us your
best one i think this is the last one
hopefully this plays
others check out these bears climbing
out of a a well
that's a mom
that's so funny so what happened
well yeah so what happens is they were
trapped under there so wildlife
officials
the department of game wildlife and fish
or whatever you call it
they put a ladder there and then they
were able to figure out how to climb
that ladder up from the well
and go out and they're the cubs they
climbed out together cool damn
all of them figured out yeah that's in
monrovia
well you gotta get out of there that's
whenever my i have bears in my well
whenever i'm like this water tastes so
[ __ ] berry
well there's my water's super quickly
i go man does your bear does your water
taste like brown bear and then brennan
goes i have covered i don't have any
taste
and i go well i do have taste even
though i have covert too
dude no you used to have taste right
yeah that's the first time you know you
have covered
come on dude give me give me the fact
that i have code nope
joanne johanna got her test result back
she was texting me she doesn't have it
how weird is that oh wow i know
i got to tell you i i feel pretty much
100 right now hold on
i'm just light-headed because i've been
eating anything about three days
you probably got your gun huh pete
yeah you got it then we got his custom
ar-15
i gotta go pick mine up did i send it to
you
no hell no you want to get it yeah
i gotta go pick mine up well guys this
is our first
uh zoom find the kid hopefully our last
yeah dallas july 16 17 18. come
see me go see the cobia man dallas
yeah go see the fake coconut man you
ain't got no covert boy
ain't got no covered uh this is covered
it's mild as [ __ ] so
yeah that's how it's supposed to be you
get uh salt lake city spokane irvine
irvine tickets just went on sale that is
what month is that that's august 27-29
irvine get your tickets now
uh other shows are sold out all right
t5k.com new thick boy merch comes out
drops next week
this hoodie rocking now tease tanks
everything man
d5k.com thickboy.com um
i think we did it guys the the cove
would finally uh
caught up with us until we caught up
with us but we're still okay
yeah appreciate you guys coming on man
we have reached chin do we do reads
yeah the rings you can sign out and then
we'll do it after
all right this is the fighting kid with
kelvin we're out